hace dos décadas se abría un oscuro
capítulo en la historia estadounidense
el 11 de enero de 2002 los primeros
prisioneros pisaban en guantánamo el
centro de detención abierto por el
gobierno de george w.bush recibió a las
personas acusadas por el gobierno
estadounidense de ser los presuntos
responsables de efectuar los atentados
del 11 de septiembre
puedo escucharte el resto del mundo te
escucha
las personas que derribaron estos
edificios pronto nos escucharán a todos
los primeros 20 prisioneros fueron
retenidos en el campamento ex rey en
jaulas de alambre su población creció
hasta tener un pico de unos 800 reclusos
los prisioneros duncan sido enjuiciados
por cortes de eeuu mientras que
organizaciones como amnistía
internacional denuncian que en esta
prisión los detenidos han sido sometidos
a desaparición forzada y tortura delitos
según el derecho internacional
eeuu tocó fondo en materia de derechos
humanos hace 20 años cuando abrió el
centro de detención de guantánamo y
recurrió a la tortura y a la
desaparición forzada en su guerra contra
el terror la cia reconoció haber
utilizado la técnica de ahogamiento
simulado conocida como submarino en tres
de los cautivos que fueron retenidos en
prisiones secretas y luego trasladados a
guantánamo electo en 2018 el presidente
barack obama prometió cerrarla para 2010
pero la entregó a su sucesor donald
trump en funcionamiento -yo bailén dijo
que tiene la intención de cerrar el
centro penitenciario antes de dejar el
cargo pero se desconoce de un plan
concreto para lograrlo en guantánamo
permanecen 39 reclusos de 12
nacionalidades